e aí
olá meu nome é sabrina e eu sou ansiosa
eu sou ansiosa e eu sou jornalista
jornalismo e ansiedade são praticamente
sinônimos na vida profissional eu sempre
tive a impressão de que a ansiedade era
minha amiga porque ela me fazia mais
ágil mas produtiva super produtiva
criativa eu recebia por causa disso pela
minha super produtividade vários elogios
de um monte de gente fiquei um pouco
viciada neles eu recebi a tapinhas nas
costas e de vez em quando alguém chegava
para mim perguntava nossa sabrina como é
que você consegue fazer tantas coisas e
eu respondi a que nada só que no fundo
eu queria dizer eu consigo fazer todas
essas coisas virando noites com a boca
seca e tendo taquicardia
e no final de 2012 eu fazia uma revista
semanal em belo horizonte eu fazer
pesquisas entrevistas com meu quarto
livro no rio de janeiro no complexo do
alemão lugar que eu amo ou seja eu tinha
que viajar para o rio uma vez por semana
e além desses dois trabalhos que eram
meio que fiques eu tinha outros 11
projetos profissionais 11 projetos
profissionais por quê porque eu era
viciada em futuro eu tinha vontade de
fazer coisas para não ter que lidar com
presente aos poucos eu fui percebendo
assim que aquela ansiedade toda não era
exatamente minha amiga bom eu diminuir a
minha rotina eu desacelerei pensei agora
vai agora eu vou ficar bem calmo e feliz
mas não tão rápido eu era viciada no
futuro e a gente precisa de um certo
tempo para se adaptar e consegui pensar
no presente e quando eu conseguir isso
comecei a conversar com o
oi pessoal meu redor com amigos e tudo
mais e eu cheguei à conclusão de que não
tava sozinha nessa luta que mais pessoas
tinham esse tipo de problema esse tipo
de negligência com agora com esse
instante que no final das contas é tudo
que a gente tem né e foi assim que eu
tive a ideia de fazer um experimento
social perguntar em várias cidades a
várias pessoas alguma coisa nesse
sentido ainda não tinha assim eu ainda
não tinha certeza no começo de que
pergunta se ele é essa e depois de
pensar um pouco eu defini que seria
assim se você pudesse fazer qualquer
coisa o que você faria agora agora não
você não tá entendendo se você pudesse
fazer qualquer coisa nesse mundo de meu
deus sem nenhum tipo de limite o que é
que você escolheria fazer agora
e para minha alegria as pessoas toparam
responder à minha pergunta o que eu faço
em geral das 15 cidades onde eu estive
até hoje com a minha unha amarela e
conversei com mais mais ou menos 300
pessoas eu faço assim eu fico parada do
lado da minha urna esperando que algum
curioso chega até mim geralmente
acontece de vez em quando é mais difícil
dependendo da cidade sei lá outro lugar
mas eu tô parado eu fico tentando fazer
contato visual com alguém vendo se essa
pessoa se anima vir conversar e também
tem dia que as pessoas estão muito
corridas e eu corro atrás delas para
tentar perguntar ele se você pudesse
fazer qualquer coisa o que é que você
faria agora
é viajar a maior parte das pessoas dá
alguma resposta escreve e coloca de
damião na respostas relacionadas a
viagens muito interessante a primeira
vez que eu fiz esse experimento foi em
tel aviv israel um pouco depois eu fiz
em belém uma cidade de palestinos na
cisjordânia nos dois lugares eu
verifiquei o que mais tarde se confirmou
como uma tendência dessas respostas as
pessoas querem viajar majoritariamente a
sua resposta assim que reina na urna mas
mais que isso no universo dessas pessoas
que escrevem sobre viagens a maioria
delas quer viajar acompanhada de alguém
querido ou com o objetivo de ver alguém
que ela ama então isso ela vive alguém
escreveu na minha urna que queria ver o
irmão e em belém alguém disse que queria
viajar para ver a mãe no final das
contas tem a ver com conexão humana
o e conexão humana é outro grande tema
eu gostaria de encontrar meus amigos
gostaria de dar um beijo na minha
namorada são alguns dos exemplos de
respostas de pessoas que falam que
querem só encontrar alguém na verdade
que a gente juntar o que é o que tem a
ver com as viagens que se relacionam
haver pessoas queridas e as pessoas
simplesmente independentemente de viagem
fala o que querem ver parentes namorado
amigo namorado enfim a conexão humana
passa na frente
e tem gente que me comove de verdade
mesmo e não é tão raro assim acontecer
tem gente que fala exatamente o nome das
pessoas com quem gostaria de estar
o ok mas viajar ver quem eu amo são
respostas meio que a gente poderia
prever né que elas apareceriam eu mesmo
acho que se alguém me perguntasse isso
na rua seria isso que eu falaria mas o
que eu não tava preparada quando eu
comecei esse experimento social foi para
receber as respostas tão simples que as
pessoas davam tão simples a ponto de se
resumir em comer beber
a fazer sexo
a dormir o básico o essencial o básico
do básico da vida humana puxa vida
qualquer coisa e as pessoas falam isso
eu acho bem interessante
eu e mais que isso também de vez em
quando claro rola umas respostas meio
maluquinha por exemplo sai correndo e
gritando correr e gritar são atividades
ações que a maioria de nós é capaz de
fazer sem grandes problemas o que que
nos impede essas pessoas que escreveram
para mim alguma praça por aí se elas
queriam correr e gritar por quê que vejo
tá conversando comigo ela não estão por
aí correndo e gritando se elas fizessem
isso possivelmente eu me assustaria
acharia sim sei lá esquisito que elas
eram meio malucas mas pelo menos ela
estaria fazendo que elas são vontade né
e no final das contas isso deveria
importar eu acho
a tomar banho de rio e nadar no mar é
outra resposta muito comum ela parece
muitas vezes uma delas me vem à memória
sempre porque foi em cuiabá e justamente
lá nessa cidade eu coloquei a minha urna
no lugarzinho assim bem ao lado do rio
dava até para ficar ouvindo mesmo
barulho da água alguém escreveu que
queria tomar banho no rio cuiabá e
quando eu voltei para o hotel e fui
fazer o que é uma das minhas coisas
favoritas ou seja ler as respostas das
pessoas eu vi que essa pessoa que então
tomar banho de rio que imaginando será
que essa pessoa tomou banho de rio
naquele dia será que ela se não tiver
tomado naquele dia será que ela tomou
banho de rio no dia seguinte será que
ela está por ali no dia seguinte a gente
não tem uma garantia né
e outras respostas eu gostaria de tirar
minha bota gostaria de ver um filme do
homem-aranha gostaria de dançar o
nordeste nunca decepciona e foi onde
mais eu recebi essa resposta sobre dança
na bahia particularmente alguém disse
que queria dançar com o dom e em são
luís do maranhão como não poderia ser
diferente alguém disse que queria dançar
um reggae gostei
a ir para o espaço porque não viver mais
intensamente as respostas essas variadas
assim me chama atenção mas são ainda
mais a minha atenção as respostas que
são raras por exemplo só uma pessoa
disse que queria fazer compras mesmo com
todo o apelo que a gente tem o tempo
inteiro da publicidade do varejo uma
pessoa apenas respondeu que queria fazer
compras
é também uma pessoa só responder o que
queria ganhar na loteria e ninguém nunca
em nenhum lugar ninguém nunca me disse
que queria tirar uma foto muito bonita
para arrasar nas redes sociais ganhar
muitos likes fórum compartilhamento
ninguém nunca disse isso
é só três pessoas me falaram ou seja
quase que uma para cada 100 né se eu
conversei com quase 300 que estavam
fazendo naquele instante exatamente
aquelas queriam uma em cada 100 pessoas
eu acho que é algo para a gente pensar
uma em cada 100 pessoas me disse que
tava já fazendo aquilo que queria o que
aprendi com a minha urna até agora que
eu pretendo continuar com ela por aí por
muito tempo porque eu aprendi com essas
pessoas generosos a ponte de conversar
com mais conhecida como eu na rua ou na
praça pública o que aprendi com essas
pessoas curiosas o suficiente para
participar desse experimento foi que eu
sou bem parecida com elas e depois que
eu descobri isso agora me acho parecida
com todo mundo após que também como
vocês eu me sinto parecida com as
pessoas de duas formas
é a primeira delas é nos desejos simples
não estou dizendo que a gente não tenha
sonhos grandiosas ou meta ambiciosa os
ok isso pode variar de pessoa para
pessoa mais acho que os desejos simples
são uma base comum é algo que nos
aproximam nos assemelha a outra coisa a
segunda coisa é que esses desejos
simples tendem a ser negligenciados a
gente deixa para depois das nossas
vantagens como se estivesse assim todo
tempo do mundo a gente abre mão do
presente com muita facilidade né a gente
se esquece que o presente é tudo que a
gente tem
olá eu sou uma ansiosa em recuperação
hoje eu quero falar com vocês que eu já
não estou mais disposta a abrir mão do
meu presente por nada nem das festinhas
de família nem dos abraço nas pessoas
que eu amo nem de mergulhar no rio é o
exercício um dia por vez eu quero fazer
essa pergunta para vocês vocês receberão
dentro do caderninho que vem no kit um
papelzinho amarelinho e mal cortado
igual esse todo que vocês viram agora a
pouco eu gostaria que vocês respondessem
para mim por favor essa pergunta se você
pudesse fazer qualquer coisa o que você
faria agora a minha urna vai tá
esperando por vocês no final lá perto de
onde vocês fizeram credenciamento e mais
importante que tudo eu gostaria que
vocês pensassem junto comigo numa outra
pergunta que é essa que eu tenho feito
não na praça mais mas para mim mesma e
divido agora com vocês se não for agora
quando
e aí
bom obrigada tá